thank you for joining us on this
historic day
it's an honor to be here with all of you
when the president asked me to serve in
this role
we talked about the importance of
bringing truth and transparency
back to the briefing room and he asked
me to ensure
we are communicating about the policies
across the biden harris administration
and the work his team is doing every
single day on behalf of all american
people
there will be times when we see things
differently in this room i mean among
all of us
that's okay that's part of our democracy
and rebuilding trust with the american
people
will be central to our focus in the
press office and in the white house
every single day so we had a very busy
and active day today as you all know
but i wanted to take a moment to uh go
through
uh the 15 executive actions or
highlights of them i should say
uh and some of the age the the steps
that the president asked agencies to
take today
you should have all received copies of
the executive orders as well as the
accompanying fact sheets
but i want to take this moment to
highlight them for the american public
who are watching at home to combat the
deadly
virus the president launched his 100-day
masking challenge
asking americans to do their part and
mask up for 100 days
he's doing his part as well issuing a
mask mandate
that will require anyone visiting a
federal building or federal land or
using certain modes of public
transportation
to wear a mask he signs an executive
order
reversing trump's decision to withdraw
from the world health organization
this will strengthen our own efforts to
get the pandemic under control by
improving global health and tomorrow
we're not wasting any time
dr fauci will participate remotely in
the meeting of the world health
organization
as the u.s head of delegation president
biden also
officially appointed a covid 19 response
coordinator
a position and team we had already
previously announced
but made it official today to create a
unified national response to the
pandemic
and he reestablished the national
security team responsible
for global health security and bio
defense
the kovan 19 pandemic has triggered an
almost unprecedented
housing affordability crisis he took
immediate action to confront the crisis
and ask relevant agencies to extend
nationwide moratoriums on evictions and
foreclosures the pandemic has also
increased the hardship on millions of
americans
who owe federal student loans in
response the president asked the
department of education
to extend the pause on student loan
payments and interest
he rejoined the paris climate agreement
putting the united states
back in a position to exercise exercise
global leadership
and advancing the objectives of the
ambitious agreement
sorry hope you're comfortable there's a
few more
and a second broad executive order will
roll back harmful regulatory reversals
made by the previous administration to
protect public health
and the environment this order protects
our nation's treasures by
reviewing the boundaries for several
national monuments
places a temporary moratorium on all oil
and natural gas leasing in the arctic
national wildlife refuge and
re-establishes the inter-agency working
group on the social cost of greenhouse
gases
he also launched a whole-of-government
effort to advance
racial equity and root out systemic
racism
from federal programs and institutions
he directed the secretary of homeland
security
in consultation with the attorney
general to take all appropriate actions
to preserve and fortify
daca which provides temporary relief
from deportation to dreamers
young people who were brought to this
country as children
the president also put an end to the
muslim ban of policy rooted in religious
animus and xenophobia
he signed a proclamation effective
immediately
halting further funding or construction
of the previous administration's
border wall and terminating the
so-called national emergency
used to wastefully divert billions for
wall construction
also today president biden
sent an immigration bill to congress the
u.s citizenship act modernizes our
immigration system
it provides hard-working people who've
enriched our communities and lived here
for decades an opportunity to earn
citizenship
the president's priority reflected in
the bill are to
responsibly manage the border keep
families together
grow our economy address the root causes
of migration from central america
and ensure that america can remain a
refuge for those fleeing
prosecution